المزاج هنا أسود وقديم
من وقت ماضي أوكرانيا لم تشعر أنها
كانت تربح وتتحمل خسائر فادحة
وتكافح من أجل الصمود ،
لكن العدو الروسي شيء جديد
هذا هو خط المواجهة مع
المواقع الروسية حرفيًا على بعد مائة
متر من المكان  أنا
أقف الكرملين يريد حقًا مدينة
باشموت ،
لذا فقد أرسل هنا على أطرافها
مرتزقة لا يرحمون من مجموعة فاغنر
لمحاربة القصف بلا نهاية ،
فنحن ننتقل إلى وجهة نظرهم
حيث يرون مقاتلي واغنر
يندفعون نحوهم وهم يقودون  الأوكرانيون
يطلقون النار وهم هناك
يقولون أن مرتزقة واغنر الروس يحاولون على ما
يبدو أن يركضوا نحوهم
ويكشفون المواقع الأوكرانية حتى
تتمكن المدفعية الروسية من ضرب
الحقول التي تفصل بينها آثار متفحمة
، وكادوا أن يجرؤوا
على النظر في الهجوم التالي.  على وشك
أن نرى وحدة هاون يقول مشغل الطائرة بدون طيار
إنهم يستعدون لإطلاق النار
علينا في الملجأ الذي قال القائد
إنهم استولوا عليه  د-
تم إطلاق النار على المدانين الروس الذين تم تجنيدهم لمحاربته أو الاستسلام
للمدان الذي يقول إن فاغنر يتصرف بشكل
احترافي ليس مثل قذائف وحدات المشاة المعتادة
التي
تستمر في
التحضير للقتال من شارع إلى شارع
، وفي الوقت نفسه تمزق إلى
أشلاء الخسائر كبيرة في
المواقع المكشوفة حول  مدينة خاصة
هنا
غزو روسيا الذي مزق
الأرض الخضراء العزيزة التي تدعي أنها تغطيها
لماذا يريدون الباشموس
عولجوا في مكان آخر
ويحتاجون إلى نصر وهو شيء مهم
كما يقول ، لذا فهم يرمون القوات هنا
بالطبع لدينا ضحايا ليس اليوم في
وحدتنا  لكن لا يمكنك تجنب الموت أو
الجرحى أحيانًا بجروح خطيرة لقد فقدت
صديقي المقرب بعد خمسة أيام من مجيئنا إلى
هنا
على بعد بضعة طرق وريعا لركوب الدراجات إلى المنزل
تخبرك عيناه كيف أن الحياة هنا هي
إطلاق النار أولاً ولكن لا توجد
كهرباء أو ماء ليس كذلك  سيء للغاية
فقط تم تدمير كل منزل ثان
، ولا يزال هناك الكثير من الناس هنا
يشترون الكثير من بطاطس ناتاليا
التي بعناها نصف طن  قالت في اليوم الذي تقول فيه إن من
يدري ما إذا كان القصف قادمًا أم
لا تخاف ، قالت بعد
24 ساعة والمدفعية الأوكرانية
تضرب مواقع على حافة المدينة
وسط تقارير أن روسيا قد اقتربت
كثيرًا من الدخان الجديد ومن الصعب دائمًا
معرفة ما تعتقده موسكو  كان يضرب
المشي إلى المنزل مع عجلة صرير
والطعام يعود ماريا إلى ابنها
الصمت والرعب بدوره
يغلف المدينة
نيك بايتون والش سي إن باخمان أوكرانيا